hello and welcome to the new world of
your source for everything anime and
manga and today i would like to tackle
an intriguing hunter hunter question
that has yet to be answered within the
story or by togashi which is
why did kalato join the phantom troupe
hmm
oh and also another question that has
yet to be answered which is why haven't
you yet subscribed to the new world
review in order to receive regular hunt
onto content uploaded straight into your
youtube feed so let's hit that button
join the association and we'll live
happily ever after oh and if you're a
pokemon fan i also have a pokemon
channel now it's fun
link in the description subscribe to
that as well because why not
anyway enough shilling i want to get
into today's topic because i feel like
color toe is a very forgotten about
factor of huntante amongst a
sea of many forgotten factors but carla
took quite possibly for very good reason
because when he joined the troop well
that coincided with that whole time when
they were pushed into the background
during greed island and yeah they got a
sliver of time during the chimera
antarctic but they really would not be
truly active again until the whole
succession war business however this is
one of the more intriguing and lingering
questions of hunt hunter and quite
deceptively so because oddly enough we
do have an answer from kaluto himself in
regards to why he joined the troop which
was presented to us in chapter 229 and
for some context this took place during
the troops invasion of zazan's hive in
meteor city and kalato is taken aback by
the sheer power of the other troop
members and then he goes on to say this
i underestimated them i thought i'd rise
quickly in their ranks
i'm far inferior almost helpless but i
won't give up
i'm used to waiting it out no matter how
many years it takes
i want to get my brother back so that
right there is our
opening answer as to why kalato has
joined the phantom troupe and very
intriguingly it expresses not only a
desire to climb to the apex of their
ranks but also this whole business about
getting his brother back and the brother
part is obviously what we're going to be
focusing on for the majority of this
video because there are a wide array of
ideas concerning this however to be
perfectly honest with you
none of them fit particularly neatly and
it's just so strange because you would
think that the word brother kind of
gives away the game here because due to
our understanding of the zoldic family
in theory we should already know and be
able to identify who
said brother is and so let's take a look
at carloto's siblings right now and of
course we have illumi milikey kilwa and
alaka and initially we are looking at
four options right off the bat two of
which i believe we can immediately
remove
firstly illumi zaldik is incredibly
unlikely to be this candidate because he
is very much the ideal zaldik family
heir he's a perfect assassin with some
crazy desires but illumi isn't a
character who really fits the idea of
needing to be brought back either
physically or emotionally and i make
that distinction because kalato's words
are not clear not clear at all and he
could be talking about something deeper
like restoring his brother back to what
he
once was or something along those lines
furthermore illimi and kalato are the
most removed of the zoldic siblings with
ill me being the oldest and colour to
being the youngest so it's highly
unlikely that these two have developed
the kind of bonds that kalato seems to
be displaying here and the other
candidate i think we can rule out
immediately is milike because
while more of a misfit than illumi
milikey is generally a good zoltic boy
who also has not exhibited any need of
you know being brought
back milikey spends most of his time
physically at the estate and he has
never shown any significant personal
growth or change so i really do not see
kalato doing something like joining the
phantom troupe simply for the sake of
milikey so that leaves us with killua
and alaka both of whom i believe have
some real merit in being the focus of
kalato's desire
and we're going to take some time to
explore their cases individually but i
also want to say right here and now that
there is in fact
a third option a character who is not
part of the zoltik family that we are
aware of
but does have admittedly an alright
chunk of evidence going in his favor so
look forward to that reveal but to start
this discussion off let's look at who
many would consider the obvious
candidate
mr killua and on a surface level killua
makes a lot of sense as he has not only
physically distanced himself from his
orderic family but he has also made
something of an effort to cut ties with
them in general he is in no way
interested in pursuing the family
business much less running it and his
personality has undergone rapid growth
over the course of the series which in
the eyes of kalato would probably seem
like a distant removal of what killua
once was
plus killer being the middle child in
carloto being the youngest it becomes
much more likely that the two of them
were able to develop some sort of strong
sibling relationship although to be fair
the series itself gives us next to
nothing to confirm this in hunter hunter
we explore a lot of killerworth's
relationship with ilmi milikey and alka
pretty much to the point where there is
no room left for misconception
we understand the nature of all three of
those relationships very clearly
on the other hand we haven't really seen
kalato interact with killua although
kalato did take an intrigued interest in
the events of the zaldik family arc so
with that in mind
yet it is somewhat plausible to see
kilowatt's return being kalato's goal
but the question would then become
why join the phantom troop to accomplish
that because following the events of
york knew the troop no longer had any
interest in killua and they start to go
down a very separate path furthermore
and this is something that we'll come
back to with alaka as well but in the
modern day events kalato is currently
with the troop aboard the black whale
one headed to the dark continent which
is pretty counterproductive in getting
killer back because he is currently
still
in the realm of humanity so yeah kalatok
could just be following orders getting
stronger and hoping to rise high enough
within the troop to do
to do what though how does koloto plan
on using his position within the troop
to get
killer back there's a pretty big
disconnect of ideas happening here with
the eventual goal not really fitting the
plotted course of action which does
force us to consider other ideas and one
of those ideas is
alaka now something interesting to
remember is that kalato is actually
younger than alaka
which means that they may have a similar
relationship to that of alaka and
kilauea albeit probably not one with op
wish granting benefits furthermore alika
is a character who does
genuinely fit the bill of someone you
would want to get back because even
though she for most of her life was kept
safely within the zoldic family estate
she was segregated from the rest of her
family following the discovery of nanika
within her so there is a potential
motivation for kalito here in terms of
rescuing alaka from this effective
imprisonment and also given that naninka
may not have always existed within alika
or at least it may not have shown itself
in her initial years that is also
something that could be viewed as
needing rescuing from you know this
overwhelmingly powerful presence which
could seem like a possession from the
perspective of those who aren't familiar
with nanika and yes i should also note
that alaka is now free and travelling
with gila but alaka may not necessarily
know that depending on what illumi
has chosen to inform him off and even if
kalato did then there's still the idea
of needing to save alakar from nanika
which is one possible way in which you
may want to focus your efforts on the
phantom troop you know rise to the top
of their ranks and then use their power
in some way to combat that presence
within alaka and yeah i'm sure it really
wouldn't work out that way but kalato is
very young and may not know any better
furthermore it may be even more simple
than that because it has been
established that the zelda children are
given fairly outrageous tasks at very
young age such as killer being sent to
heaven's arena and being told not to
return until he had reached the 200th
floor so perhaps carlito was given a
similar task to infiltrate the phantom
troop and not return home
until he had effectively reached second
in command of the organization and i
actually think that's a very likely
explanation for why kalito joined but it
also might come with the added bonus of
silva or xeno promising to release alaka
upon the completion of that task now so
just to briefly address a comment i know
is bound to come up regarding alaka's
gender
even if kalato had the kind of
relationship with alika the killer does
it is conceivable that kalato would
still refer to alika as his brother
because that's just how the rest of the
family operate
so the whole getting back of a brother
very much applies to alika here as well
as for just how likely this is to be the
case as opposed to killer
well to be fair i should say that the
phantom troop task argument
could apply to killer as well and upon
completing of becoming the number two of
the organization
silva could have some plan to take back
killer into their household or i know
something along those lines both kilauea
and alaka are very shaky thoughts still
there is one more theory i'd like to go
over and it involves our mystery
candidate who many of you probably have
guessed by now but for those of you who
haven't may i present to you
mr feitan now for far longer than i've
been a hunter hunt fan it has been
speculated that feitan is in fact a
zoldick and through a variety of
circumstances he left the family one
interesting one of which is that alaka
may have accidentally exiled him and
erased his memory through one of her
unreasonable requests
and feitan does bear a lot of
coincidental similarities to soldier
youth with a small slender stature
sneaky assassin eyes and some trademark
zoldick's spiky hair
now this is a long shot obviously and
there's a ton of evidence stacked
against it like the fact that feitan's
name doesn't fit into the zoldik family
naming scheme
and also the fact that he does have an
actual last name which is porter but at
the same time this could easily be an
alias
faetan's age is also unknown meaning
that he could possibly be even older
than illumi
although that would make kikio a very
very young mummy but the reason why this
whole phaeton zodiac idea takes off
is because when you solely consider the
context of carlto's actions the idea of
him wanting to take feitan back
is almost the most plausible of the
bunch so first up remember that initial
quote i had for you from chapter 229
where kalato makes his brother saving
statement well it's actually very
important to give you a bit more context
than that because kalito actually said
that whilst he was watching feitan fight
against azan now it might be easy to
dismiss this as a coincidental
juxtaposition but
feitan is a huge focus of kaluto's
attention here and very
very interestingly at one stage in both
the anime and the manga a family photo
of the zoldicks is shown when carlotto
makes a statement about getting his
brother back and initially you may think
this removes feitan from all contention
whatsoever
because he's obviously not present in
the picture all zeldik children are
accounted for at the same time though
on that very page right after the photo
is a focused panel of feitan which is
balanced more or less equally to the
panel that this photo takes up and here
is where
the artsy wanker within me is going to
take over because i think there is a
fantastic argument to be made that this
is togashi
clearly connecting feitan to the zoldik
family primarily by giving them equal
visual balance
his family absence in the picture was
intentional and only serves to highlight
what color tone may be fighting for
to get feiten back into the family that
he is missing from when this picture was
taken and yes i know it's a crackpot
idea but the juxtaposition of these two
panels is so powerful because it does
link feitan to the zodiks under the
right context and it goes on to frame
kalato's actions as making perfect sense
the phantom troupe isn't some random
organization that was chosen for him the
phantom troupe is actually directly
connected to kalato's goal because it
contains feitan but now i do also have
to address the plethora of problems with
this theory which range from simple
things like the fact that phaeton is a
transmuter which is fine many zoltics
are but only when they have white hair
only whitehead zodic family members are
transmuters whilst every member with
black hair is a manipulator so feiten
being a transmute with black hair
doesn't quite fit the bill furthermore
there are even some glaring questions
like why doesn't killua recognize feitan
when he encounters him and the only
possible counter-argument against such
evidence is some sort of shenaniganory
that has gone down featuring alika you
know like alaka somehow exiling feitan
as well as removing the memories from
the rest of the zodiac family members
with the exception of kalato for
some reason and maybe there is some
merit to this like the idea that alaka
and nanika plonked themselves into the
zoldic family in feitan's place but it's
getting to the point of pretty crazy
speculation here there's a lot of mental
gymnastics to engage in to make this
idea truly plausible
regardless of how much raw sense it
makes into the soul context of kalato's
actions but there you have it for now it
could be something as simple as killer
something more left field like calico
or something completely insane like the
phaeton zodic theory and that is why
this one
simple statement from kalato is one of
the most enduring mysteries
in hunter hunter but what do you guys
think please do leave your thoughts in
the comments below or even join my
discord server and if you're keen for
some more hunt hunter content then
please to go and check out some of my
other videos or even subscribe to the
channel for regular hunt hunter glory
delivered straight
into your youtube feed but for now this
has been the new world review and i'll
see you next time